vous cherchez une période mais vous vous
intéressez à la TCL c845 vous avez
raison j'ai donc vous donner 10 raisons
de venir choisir la tesselle c845 quel
que soit la taille de l'écran avant tout
est-ce que vous connaissez TCL TCL
fabrique aussi bien des téléviseurs des
barres de son des réfrigérateurs des
climatiseurs des machines à laver bref
TCL à une offre complète pour la maison
il est notamment l'un des leaders dans
la vente de téléviseur et le leader sur
la vente de format 98 pouces cette année
il y a une nouvelle gamme C64 c'est 74
c'est 84 nous on va s'intéresser au plus
haut de gamme au C84 avec le modèle
c'est 845 et la première raison pour
laquelle il faut venir choisir ce modèle
et bien c'est son design on a des bords
fins on a un design en métal qui donne
un côté extrêmement Premium avec deux
solutions soit vous le posez sur un
meuble télé auquel cas vous avez un pied
central soit vous pouvez venir également
l'accrocher un mur ici vous le voyez on
a un pied central autre qui est
extrêmement pratique sur ce téléviseur
c'est le passage de câbles au niveau du
pied central vous récupérez votre cadre
d'alimentation qui est sur la gauche
vous différents câbles qui court sur vos
connectiques à droite vous les faites
passer au centre ce qui fait que c'est
totalement invisible et c'est beaucoup
plus esthétique et vachement bien
surtout la modularité il existe ici en
cas de taille 55 pouces 65 pouces comme
ce que j'ai derrière vous avez également
le 75 pouces et le 85 pouces donc ça va
vraiment dépendre de la taille de votre
intérieur dans l'ensemble de cette gamme
on se parle de téléviseur mini LED et de
cul LED autant vous dire qu'ici on est
quand même dans le haut du panier les
finitions sont irréprochables téléviseur
est super jolie même la télécommande est
vraiment extrêmement pratique parce que
je vais aimer c'est les petits
raccourcis que vous avez en bas vous
pouvez choisir entre Netflix YouTube
prime vidéo et même les chaînes de TCL
sur cette télécommande vous avez
également la touche Google assistant qui
est extrêmement pratique soit vous dites
ok Google et auquel cas bien vous allez
lui dire ce que vous voulez soit vous
appuyez sur la touche et vous parlez
sans énoncer les mots magiques c'est
tout aussi pratique le deuxième point le
très gros point c'est la techno d'écran
TCL maîtrise réellement on ces écrans il
vous propose ici une dalle mini LED vous
montez jusqu'à 896 zones d'affichage sur
le modèle en 85 pouces et 576 zones
d'affichage sur le modèle en 65 pouces
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire beaucoup
de détails dans votre image les détails
mais pas seulement vous avez aussi un
milliard de couleurs grâce à la
technologie
Q LED et grâce à ses anneaux cristaux
Inor que vous aurez des couleurs
ultra réalistes on se parle ici bien
évidemment d'un téléviseur 4K HDR
premium 2000 avec plein de techno IMAX
le motion clarity qui permet d'avoir
moins de flou et plus de détails Dolby
vision IQ et il est en plus de sa
certifié par toy reyland pour des
faibles émissions de lumière bleue
autant vous dire que lui prend soin de
vos yeux et vous donne beaucoup de
confort visionnage le troisième point
c'est la luminosité on va monter ici
jusqu'à 2000 needs maximum pas besoin de
mettre de ministre lorsque vous regardez
un film à la maison le soir mais lorsque
vous avez des baies vitrées à côté où il
y a beaucoup de lumière vous pouvez
monter la luminosité extrêmement haute
permettra d'afficher tous vos contenus
sans aucun problème et l'autre point qui
est vraiment cool ici c'est que vous
avez un grand angle de vision et quand
vous invitez du monde à la maison pour
des matchs ou pour venir jouer à la
console quand même plutôt cool quatrième
point c'est l'expérience audio on a ici
un son signé Onkyo Dolby Atmos 2.1 avec
des basses qui ronronnent alors vous
pouvez bien évidemment prendre cette SL
une barre de son en complément mais le
son tel qu'il est là délivré par le
téléviseur il ira parfaitement bien
jouera totalement son rôle d'immersion
lorsque vous regardez des films et des
séries cinquième point c'est le gaming
vous montez jusqu'à 144 vrr vous avez
également le motion clarity pro qui
apportera énormément de fluidité lorsque
vous allez venir jouer à vos jeux pas de
sac à non plus avec la MD free 5 premium
pro sans oublier le mode jeu le gaming
mode pour venir optimiser totalement
l'affichage sur votre téléviseur alors
quel que soit votre console quel que
soit vos jeux vous allez vraiment avoir
une expérience incroyable lors de votre
grosse session de jeu 6e point c'est
Google TV c'est l'une des meilleures
expériences sur une télé connectée
est-ce que nous propose Google TV entre
autres et bien c'est de profiter de
l'assistant Google avec OK Google je
veux regarder Mission Impossible mycanal
prime vidéo mycanal mycanal vous avez
également Google meet et surtout Google
TV est un super agrégateur de contenu
raison qu'on trouve en un seul et même
endroit tous vos contenus la recherche
est extrêmement simplifiée et lorsque
vous switcherez sur votre smartphone et
bien vous allez avoir une continuité au
niveau de l'expérience ce qui est aussi
génial avec Google TV c'est que vous
avez toutes vos applications favorites
Netflix Disney plus prime vidéo Molotov
mais également plein d'applications on a
Spotify par exemple et aussi pas mal de
jeux donc de quoi avoir du contenu
complet pour toute la famille et pour
tous les besoins et en plus de ça il est
même compatible Amazon Alexa
septième point ce sont tous les modes
dédiés que vous avez alors on va avoir
un mode plus économie d'énergie pour une
utilisation un peu courante et vous avez
comme je vous l'ai dit ce mode gaming on
a également un mode dédié pour venir
regarder des films et des séries sans
oublier le mode Sport lorsque vous allez
venir regarder différents matchs je
pense notamment la Coupe du monde de
rugby qui vont arriver à la fin de
l'année ou pourquoi pas les matchs de
foot qui est génial c'est le mode
ordinateur vous pouvez me dire brancher
directement votre ordinateur sur une
prise HDMI si vous avez besoin de
diffuser une présentation vous voulez
montrer des photos des souvenirs de
vacances vous pouvez le faire très
facilement et également pour le
télétravail à côté très très pratique 8e
point il est compatible AirPlay 2 et
homekit qui vous permet de venir
afficher le contenu de votre smartphone
de votre MAC de votre iPad directement
sur votre téléviseur vous pouvez
commencer à regarder une série sur votre
télé et continuer ensuite j'en sais rien
si vous voulez aller vous balader aller
dehors aller dans votre chambre sur
votre tablette sur votre Mac sur votre
iPhone comme vous voulez et vous pilotez
en plus de ça votre maison connectée
très facilement et ça c'est quand même
plutôt cool le neuvième point c'est la
performance on a à l'intérieur
IP you processeur 3.0 qui va venir
analyser les différentes zones de votre
image pour maximiser le rendu avec par
exemple
qui va venir ici optimiser la résolution
de l'image à e-color pour les couleurs
aie HDR qui sera en plus de ça
compatible avec plusieurs format HDR là
il motion pour apporter plus de fluidité
et là il contraste on l'aura compris
pour les contrastes autant vous dire
qu'ici vous avez de la performance sous
le capot pour profiter d'une expérience
de visionnage inégalée autrement qui est
super intéressant c'est la connectique
vous avez pas mal de collectif à
l'arrière USB 2.0 RJ45 HDMI 4K 144 Hz on
a également un autre port HDMI 4K 120 Hz
et deux autres entrées HDMI 4K 60 hertz
donc de quoi brancher vos consoles de
jeu et d'ailleurs pourquoi pas baisser
vous avez également des prises antennes
et satellites une sortie optique des
prises avaient et une prise jack 3.5 et
puis le dixième point c'est le tarif en
un tarif qui est maîtrisé pour voir
qu'on est sur un téléviseur très haut de
gamme on est à
1290 euros bon il est temps de vous
donner mon retour sur cette téléviseur
sur ce TCL c845 c'est une très très
belle évolution du TCL c835 qui apporte
son lot de nouveautés à commencer par la
luminosité je sais pas si vous allez
être rendu compte dans la vidéo il y a
des moments où la luminosité est
tellement forte qu'on a l'impression que
l'image est cramé mais en fait c'est
parce que à l'oeil nu je me rends pas
compte l'image est là elle est belle
elle est nickel mais par contre la
caméra elle elle a fait un peu la gueule
par moment alors ça dépend des plans
mais par exemple sur les plans gaming
Mario Kart on voit que tout est un petit
peu cramé tout simplement pourquoi parce
que il y a luminosité est à fond nous en
jouant c'est extrêmement confortable
d'autant plus qu'à une source de lumière
sur le côté qui emmène vraiment la
lumière du jour qui était très forte
donc on voit très bien la télé il y a
aucun problème mais pour la caméra c'est
un peu complexe qui veut donc dire que
vous avez une télévision qui est
extrêmement lumineuse par défaut il y a
la luminosité adaptative qui est coché
ce qui fait que vous n'allez pas prendre
la luminosité en pleine poire dans la
tronche directement si comme moi vous
avez besoin de tournage vous pouvez
venir la régler directement avec votre
télécommande en allant dans les menus
mais c'est extrêmement confortable c'est
très lumineux et là-dessus il y a
absolument aucun problème on était
génial c'est que vous avez les dernières
techno les minimes sont vraiment de
super qualité on a beaucoup de détails
et le truc qui est génial c'est que vous
avez un contraste qui vraiment élevé
pour voir qu'on est sur du LCD alors ça
merci au cullettes derrière grâce au
quantum d'hôtes ça nous permet d'avoir
un très très bon équilibre entre d'un
côté du détail du contraste et en plus
de ça de très belles couleurs parce que
cette télé elle est en plus extrêmement
bien calibré autre point qui est aussi
super cool c'est télécommande vous avez
deux façons de dire la connecter alors
soit en infrarouge pour piloter
directement soit vous la connectez en
Bluetooth vous venez l'appairer au début
qui est aussi globalement pas trop mal
parce que si vous êtes télécommande dans
le dos ça marchera quand même bon je
vois pas l'intérêt de mettre la
télécommande dans le dos pour venir
piloter votre télé mais si vous voulez
le faire vous pouvez le faire et là
aussi quelques points un peu plus
négatifs les angles de vision qui même
s'ils sont pas mauvais sont pas non plus
parfaits au centre c'est vraiment top
100 un petit peu côté c'est top mais si
on se décale un petit peu arrivera un
moment où le rendu sera un peu moins
qualitatif une fois de plus on peut pas
tout avoir autre point qui a un petit
peu en dessous c'est l'anti-réfection on
va quand même pas trop mal les reflets
donc si vous avez une grande baie vitrée
derrière peut-être il va falloir venir
réfléchir et la disposer autrement et il
y a un autre truc qui est quand même
plutôt cool au niveau du gaming c'est à
dire que vous voyez par défaut vous avez
une entrée HDMI en 4K 144 Hertz donc
pour bien brancher une console c'est
très bien et beaucoup de fluidité mais
on peut monter jusqu'en 240 Hertz 240
Hertz oui mais en 1080p pas en cas donc
si vous voulez jouer en 1080p en 240
Hertz vous pouvez le faire mais pas en
4K et puis le dernier point qu'il faut
vraiment venir souligner c'est que même
si ça reste un certain budget on est sur
une excellent rapport qualité-prix si
vous voulez une très belle dalle on se
parle ici de la version 65 pouces que je
vous ai montré même si je vous dis dès
le départ il y a d'autres versions
d'autres configuration qui existent vous
avez une super dalle qui est très bien
maîtrisée soit l'expérience Google TV
qui fonctionne une merveilleusement bien
bref si vous voulez un super rapport
qualité-prix dans le haut de gamme vous
pouvez aller les yeux fermés sur cette
TCL c'est 845 vous avez toutes ces
techno et bien plus encore directement
disponible sur votre c845 de TCL donc si
vous intéresse bien évidemment je vous
mets un lien en bas dans la description
c'est à dire dites-moi vous qu'est-ce
qui vous intéresse le plus est-ce que
c'est plus le mini LED le cul LED
l'ensemble d'ailleurs mini lead Q LED
est-ce que c'est le mode gaming est-ce
que vous êtes un plutôt spectateur de
films de série est-ce que vous jouez à
la console marquez moi ça bien
évidemment dans les commentaires et je
vous invite à venir découvrir cette
vidéo pour tout savoir sur l'écosystème
de TCL je l'ai réalisé il y a quelques
mois on a fait un petit tour complet on
parle de télé on parle de barre de son
on parle d'électroménager comme ça vous
aurez une vision à 360 degrés surtout ce
que vous postez c'est elle